Frost again there'll be just a few
wintry showers near exposed coasts in
the north and west bringing icy
stretches they will move a little
further Inland overnight with some snow
especially on Higher Ground
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this is Sky News Tonight coming up we're
going to be answering your questions
about coping with the freezing weather
and Rising Energy prices in our special
cold weather q a that's next
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back now it has got very chilly
of late hasn't it and as temperatures
across most of the country fall well
below freezing millions of people are
understandably worried about the cost of
switching on their heating Rising Energy
prices driven by the war in Ukraine and
sanctions against Russia as well I mean
the cost of keeping your home warm is a
concern for people across Britain well
tonight we're answering your questions
in a cold weather Q and A and with me
this evening a GP Dr Helen Salisbury
personal finance expert Jasmine bertels
and Helen Barnard from the Joseph
Roundtree Foundation great to have you
all with us this evening thank you very
much uh for for being here and uh Dr
Helen Salisbury perhaps we can start
with you first what's your advice to
vulnerable people who are really
concerned about the cost of heating
their homes
I think it's a really really difficult
time but it's important to remember that
being in a cold home is actually not
good for your health at all so we
recommend that you keep the room that
you're in
um at about 18 degrees particularly if
you're over 65 particularly if you have
Mobility problems
um ideally get up and move around every
hour or so because you're sitting still
you're more likely to get cold but
really 18 degrees is the recommended
temperature and that I know that's hard
given the current temperatures yeah it
is difficult but that is the advice and
given that Jasmine bertels one of our
viewers has asked this question what are
the best settings to use for central
heating to heat your home is it better
to have a timer on and have big bursts
at those moments in the day when you
really need it or is it better to
perhaps have it on a lower setting but
keep it on all day
yes good question this has come up a lot
recently I checked with the Energy
savings trust and they said it's better
to do it here and there as and when you
need it not have it on all the time and
in fact that's what I do
um I'll have it on for an hour or so and
the rest of the time once it's sort of
warmed up a bit I've got as you can see
I've got my jumpers on I've got you know
layers
um sheepskin boots those are I think
sheepskin and wool are probably the best
ways of staying warm
um and also you know as Helen said
heating up the room that you're in or
even exactly where you're sitting
um another thing that I have is a heated
over blanket so sitting in a sofa for
example you can have this heated over
blanket over you and frankly it doesn't
matter what's happening in the rest of
the room you're warm yeah um good advice
um and Helen Barnard we know that the
government are helping out in this
situation but there have been lots of
headlines recently uh haven't there and
I know that you're not necessary
necessarily happy with all the help that
is coming people's way but just remind
us what is available
well so there has been help there have
been the cost of living packages with
one-off grants and so on uh when we get
to next April there will be a
significant rise in benefits but there
isn't more help coming this winter and
we've just done new research and we've
found that three million low-income
households can't afford to heat their
homes and actually two and a half
million can't afford to eat properly or
heat their homes so all the things the
health experts are telling people to do
to have hot drinks to keep the room warm
people simply can't afford to do those
things because the support is just
inadequate to meet the situation we're
in so get so given that Helen and
staying with you it leads us on to
another question we've had
um if I can't afford to turn on the
heating are there places I can go
especially if there are power Cuts this
winter
so there are quite a lot of people in
communities who started doing warm-ups
so it's worth looking on your local
Community page to see I've heard there's
some Bakers actually because they've got
the ovens on all the time are opening up
rooms but there is actually quite a lot
of financial support which some people
may not be getting so an awful lot of
people don't claim the benefits they
could and that would really help so it's
worth going on to a website like the
turn to us charity website where you can
do a benefit check and there is also a
tool where you can find local grants the
other thing is to talk to your energy
supplier so what we've also found as
well as the two and a half to three
million people who can't afford proper
food or heating we've got around the
same number are already in debt a
running up some high cost debt some wet
Bill arrays and people get very very
scared by that so actually speaking
early to your energy provider to say I'm
struggling with these bills they are
legally obliged to help you come to a
solution to deal with that so actually
people get very scared and they don't
want to ask for help this is a moment to
absolutely ask for help ask local
charities local Authority and your
energy supplier yeah the help is there
but people just need to to ask for it
and Jasmine I I mean one people one
thing people really worry about is is
potentially being cut off can you can
you reassure people that that won't
happen
yes um it it won't happen particularly
if you are on a contract if you're on
Direct debit
um of course if you are on a pay as you
go meter then obviously if you if you're
not paying it it's not going to come out
so
um that's you know one thing to consider
but if you are on Direct debit and you
or you know you're supposed to be on a
contract and you can't pay they're not
going to cut you off however those debts
will Mount And as Helen said it's
important to speak to your provider
actually a lot of them do have money to
help
um that tends to be sort of one-off
payments but all the major energy
suppliers they have frankly a few
hundred pounds
um to give
in certain circumstances if you qualify
so go first to your your supplier and as
Helen says try uh turn to us also try
your local Council because some local
councils not all but some local councils
have some discretionary money that they
can use to help people who are suffering
and if I could just add to what Helen
said about the warm hubs um there's a
website called warm welcome dot UK which
has a really helpful map of of the whole
of the UK with all the various warm hubs
that they're aware of and I think more
are being added as well at the same time
I mean it's incredible that we're even
having this conversation isn't it Dr
Salisbury giving people advice where to
go to keep warm what are your patients
telling you I'm sure you've seen people
over the last few weeks who've come to
you in a real State because it's not
just your physical well-being it's your
mental well-being that this affects
absolutely uh and people have people are
very worried
um and I think it sometimes it's it's
the fear that's actually being so
harmful to their health and worried
about looking after themselves worrying
about looking after
um that their their families and I quite
like to add there'd be lots of talk here
about going on websites but actually
quite a lot of the people we might be
thinking about here may not have that
capacity they may not be people who use
sites on their mobile phones they might
have mobile phones and so I think that
we also need to think about our
neighbors our friends elderly people we
know who um
might need checking up on just to make
sure that they have turned their heating
on and they're not sitting there scared
of the bills and not turning their
heating on because if we are too cold
it's it's really sad but
being in too cold environment really
increases your risk of strokes and heart
attacks and it's just not worth it so so
we need to be checking up on people and
unfortunately sometimes it may mean that
we get bills much higher than we wanted
but you know it's we do need to keep
warm and Doctor um people with certain
underlying health problems have to be
especially alert don't they in in cold
weather
absolutely
um and partly that's about
um people who can't move about but also
people who have
um lung diseases like COPD that makes
them more vulnerable
um and if you're
more likely to get in fact infections
like like flu and probably covered too
actually
um so you're less able to fight things
off if you're cold if you're breathing
in cold air
um so yes and the other thing that I
think is really quite worrying with the
the the worries of our energy costs is
people who are
um reliant on electricity for AIDS
around the home
um or for medical Machinery because I
think that's a real concern for some
people with prices going so high yeah um
yeah you make a very good point there
and I think uh just keeping an eye open
for for people in that sort of situation
it is so important isn't it in these
times
um Jasmine here's another question we've
had is it better to have a smart meter I
don't have one should I be taking
regular meter readings
well you know there are two schools of
thought here um on the one hand Smart
Meters can be useful particularly as a
number of um energy apps work with them
so there are various apps for example
there's one a new one called Ivy
um IV bud and you can find out how much
you're using when you're using it you
can also even work out which appliances
are using more than others so there is
there's there's a lot to be said for it
um but you know I'm I'm hearing quite a
number of people who are rather
concerned about
Well Control you know a lot of their
information being known by goodness
knows who you know all the information
goes up to the cloud off to the various
energy companies
um and so a lot of people are I think
understandably concerned about that so
if you're not keen on having a smart
meter then absolutely I think it's a
good idea to check your um to take some
meter readings take one once a month so
that you yourself are clear how much
you're using
um and then if you're not sure about
your bills you don't think that matches
with with what you've read then you can
complain to your your supplier well what
are the benefits Jasmine of having a
smart meter
well it's very good point it is
essentially what I've said that you can
you can see quite quickly you can
connect it to to various other apps and
gizmos that are around at the moment
um that will give you more control and
more knowledge over what you're using
and particularly in real time and that
can be handy you can have a look on one
of these
um apps or one of the these sort of
little gizmos that you can get with them
um and it'll say oh you know you you're
using up a load of electricity you'll
think how how's that happening and you
find that you've got something you know
the art you've left the iron on or
something like that so that's useful
um but primarily I think it's useful to
the energy companies actually energy
companies tell me that smart meters
enable them to know when people are
using electricity when they're using
power and that means that they can sort
out the grid better and they can they
have less wastage
um so I would say actually it's more
helpful to the energy companies and and
the the country as a whole than
individuals themselves okay interesting
um and Helen Bernard uh what support
will there be for homeless people with
temperatures dropping so low overnight
well of course we have got local
authorities
um who are we basically re-upping their
policies to try and help people get in
doing these very very cold nights but of
course we have a problem we don't have
enough affordable homes so what we often
see is people are brought in for a night
or two but they're actually finding them
somewhere sustainable to live is very
difficult and I do think we need to be
slightly careful because I think some of
the advice we're giving people to you
know use apps to stay warm can bring
quite Hollow for the people who are out
there who simply don't have the money to
turn the lights on to turn the heating
on to afford food and I do think we need
to get to grits for the fact that we
have allowed our social basic Social
Security to fall So woefully Below what
it needs to be that people can't afford
the essentials that most of us will be
taking for granted so we need to plug
the Urgent Gap this winter but actually
this is not going to go away we need to
get a better system in place so people
can can afford the essentials and they
aren't looking for warm hubs or finding
themselves ruthless when the
temperatures are plummeting yeah and Dr
Salisbury perhaps a final word from you
if we may uh for people watching this
who really are worried as they see the
weather forecast and they see the
thermometer plunge what's your advice
what's your word to them tonight
uh first of all I'd just like to endorse
what what Helen Bernard just say I mean
it is a dreadful indictment of this
country which is a rich country that
people are
suffering like this and worrying about
being able to keep
some of them just not able to keep warm
um but I guess my my advice is you know
wrap up warm if you have to just heat
one room heat that one room
um but please try and look after
yourself and look after your neighbors
yeah and I think certainly you've all
reiterated that you need to ask for help
if you need it rather than burying your
head in the sand because there is help
out there um thank you all very much
indeed it's a depressing topic but
you've given some great tips this
evening Dr Alan Salisbury Helen Barnard
Jasmine bertels uh we appreciate your
time thank you
thank you
now you're watching Sky News and coming
up in a moment The King and Queen meets
Hollywood royalty in wrexham we'll have
the details next
[Music]
there's always more to the news than a
headline we want to discover to delve a
little deeper to find out what's really
going on explanation analysis the people
at the heart of every story I'm Neil
Patterson and this is this guy News
Daily podcast Alex Crawford joining us
now from Ukraine their personal
possessions are all scattered around the
place our economics and data editor Ed
Conway try and make sense of at the big
numbers for us things can change
incredibly quickly that's what they have
done so by the end we'll hopefully all
understand what's going on in the world
just that little better available
whatever you get your podcasts
[Music]
it's about the reaction and I think we
saw that the Protection Officer stepped
in
um he went to his core competencies he
reacted spontaneously and he removed the
king away from that threat and then
other police officers part of the wider
policing plan have stepped in and dealt
with that individual it's very difficult
to legislate with regards to you know
you've got a got a royal walk about and
that that is the most pressurized kind
of Point as a Protection Officer you're
going to deal with plus as the The Wider
policing plans a lot of things to
consider how those people get in how are
they how they vetted in the form of are
they are they searched coming in so all
these considerations have to go in and
again as a Protection Officer you're
looking for what you expect to see and
what you don't expect to see but you
know the reaction is is key you know
you're always
um going to be to a certain extent on
the back foot it's how you react is the
key to dealing with that incident it's
part of a part of a wider team obviously
there's somebody that's immediately on
the king's shoulder and then as you look
around you will see other protection
officers there but the wider policing
plan as well we'll see
um
officers in the crowd they'll see
officers monitoring the crowd you know
and this is where I think we have to be
very careful you're going into an armed
policing operation there are a lot of
threats with regards to the Monarch that
you have to consider protection officers
have to consider lots of different
things and what they don't want is
somebody who is
delving into a rucksack going to reach
for something in their clothing because
they have to make a split second
decision and you know those results
could be catastrophic so I think we have
to be very very mindful of the actions
of these of these single cause issues
these protesters not all the officers
are armed you know within that wider
policing plan there will be armed
officers there'll be Firearms teams that
will come into the footprint if needed
there'll be rifle officers observing
from kind of high points and then the
last line of defense will be the
protection officers when you're looking
at a senior member of the royal family
they've had it from cradle to grave they
have built up that report or they have
built up that trust because as a
Protection Officer when you strip it all
back you were there to preserve life and
they have to trust that you can do that
so yes they do trust you and they will
take their lead from you as much as you
will take their lead from them something
they may not be comfortable with and you
have to watch that that non-verbal
communication from them as well so it's
very much a two-way street when you're
dealing with principles at this level
Sky News snow reports sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk
[Music]
on my ski hire in Europe
the Alps will see a good spell of snow
this weekend that will greatly improve
conditions especially at lower levels
where there's still not that much snow
Austria meanwhile has some good depths
on the higher slopes with plenty of ski
lifts running for the results that are
open
France has more limited skiing but more
terrain will open there this weekend
onto Italy which has more than half its
Resorts open already with more starting
their season very soon
Switzerland currently has fewer results
open with artificial snow cover in
places
Sky News snow report sponsored by snow
rental.co.uk on my ski hire in Europe
rexham had a royal visit today from King
Charles as well as a little sprinkling
of Hollywood Stardust his majesty
visited wrexham AFC and its star owners
Ryan Reynolds and Rob mcelney who bought
the club in 2020 after meeting Hollywood
royalty the king and queen went on to a
tree planting and a church visit Lisa
dad reports
this was a fixture between Hollywood
royalty and actual royalty the king and
queen consort at the glitzius club in
the Panorama League wrexham the North
Wales town that actors Ryan Reynolds and
Rob mcelhenney have really bought into a
town that's now become a city
we'll do anything to uplift and and
Elevate this community in this club and
having the king pay a visitor's uh is
certainly one way to do it our first
team manager Phil Parkinson
as they toured the area there was no
mention of the Harry and Megan Netflix
series that emerged from Hollywood this
week
not seen anything
never heard of it you don't know well
but plenty here have seen it and had
some advice
to get the boat together and just say
look
friends we don't know
the ins and outs
um and hopefully and pray that they do
all come together whatever discussions
are going on with the palace about how
best to respond to the Netflix series
those decisions won't be rushed this
visit celebrating wrexham City status
was simply the king and queen consort
getting on with the job
foreign
service celebrated wrexham's elevation a
little earlier today
I had the opportunity to see one of the
other ones
namely the football club
which is busy putting rexham on the map
as never before for now the Royals are
sticking to Safe ground but with more
episodes from Harry and Megan to come
ignoring the accusations may only get
harder Lisa Dowd Sky News wrexham
so as those temperatures plummet let's
take a look at the forecast
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well the Arctic air will potentially
remain over us for the next seven days
bringing widespread frosts ice and some
snow before then it'll be mainly dry and
cold this evening with an early Frost
again there'll be just a few wintry
showers near exposed coasts in the north
and west bringing icy stretches they'll
move a little further Inland overnight
with some snow especially on Higher
Ground expect another widespread Frost
severe in places under clear skies with
some freezing fog developing on to
Saturday morning it looks mostly dry
with plenty of sunshine but wintry
showers will continue in the north and
west they'll mostly affect Northern and
Eastern Scotland Northwest England Wales
and Northern Ireland but other Western
coasts will be at risk too
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
[Music]